comme chacun sait blanche carda je tape
pavé dans la mare à propos de de
l'émission de prime vidéo de d'Amazon
prime où elle a révélé qu'en fait les
gens étaient payés des sommes
astronomiques pour tourner une journée
et faire rire les gens ce qu'il y a ce
qui est un peu choquant puisque les
salaires vont jusqu'à 200000 € et
Virginie Efira donc réagit ce dans Le
Parisien ce matin cette polémique en
disant que elle avait trouvé blanche
Gardin extrêmement courageux mais que
l'argent qu'elle avait faisait enfin le
salaire garder ce qu'elle faisait avec
cet argent ce qu'elle a pas dit
évidemment dans le papier c'est que
elle-même a touché 150000 euros pour
avoir tourné une journée dans cette dans
cette série qui est alors c'est pas le
plus gros salaire
donc voilà elle a donné son sac elle a
touché 150.000 euros et elle dit en gros
si on lit entre le lignes que
effectivement c'est le le cinéma c'est
une grosse industrie et que bah si si on
peut se faire de l'argent comme ça c'est
plutôt
et ce qui est bien c'est qu'elle dit
voilà moi je suis conscient que je fais
partie du milieu du cinéma il y a de
l'argent on en profite et je trouve ça
beaucoup plus humble que tous les
faux-culs qui crache dans la soupe et
qui disent ne pas prendre d'argent qui
se gavent et elle en plus c'est le top
de sa carrière quand elle dit ça donc
elle a tout payé et franchement bravo
elle elle a une transparence on voulait
vraiment réagir ouais savoir ce qu'on
pense dans notre ami Raymond surtout moi
je pense que c'est très bien qu'elle le
dise parce qu'elle gagne de l'argent
c'est une valeur marchande on lui a
proposé 150000 euros elle prend il y a
pas de problème ce qui m'énerve moi
c'est quand ils arrêtent de tourner et
quand ça s'arrête comment je vais faire
maintenant c'est plus d'argent
qui m'énerve après donc tant mieux
qu'elle est prête à 250000 mais quand
vous y allez après si tu veux vraiment
ma pensée je préférerais malheureusement
qu'elle ne le dise pas parce que pour
gagner 150000 bahts tu veux ma pensée
pour 20 piges elle a gagné en une
journée quelqu'un de normal il va lui
falloir 20 piges ça c'est ma pensée sur
la normale voilà bah c'est peut-être mon
avis
courage tout le monde n'est pas aussi
fort que toi Raymond pour savoir comment
gérer son argent parfois dans la vie à
des accidents de la vie parce que mon
ami attention
j'ai pas le contraire oui Benjamin par
exemple il s'est fait escroquer je jette
pas la pierre si Benjamin il s'était pas
fait escroquer ils viennent pas me
pleurer de me dire qu'il a pas d'argent
parce que j'en ai totalement rien à
mais il demande totalement
c'est mon ami demain tu es mon ami tu me
dis cap merde il me reste plus
d'argent j'ai plus d'argent
si je peux t'aider à te payer un drôle
d'amis
de course mais je te plaindrai pas j'en
prendrai aucun souci
[Rires]
quand même honnête avec toi je serais
quand même honnêtement
[Rires]
je suis certain je te dirai de
t'emmerder
j'ai dit à la merde tous ces gens là je
suis sûr et certain
moi je suis content quand il gagne
beaucoup d'argent ce qui me fait chier
c'est qu'après quand ils viennent
pleurer il me faut 10000 € par mois pour
venir j'y arrive pas aller réfléchir
avant et moi si demain tu me retrouves
en galère bah fallait faire attention
c'est tout comme ça en galère tu as de
boulot c'est comme ça je vais peut-être
même j'en aurai trois en avoir quatre
jours
c'est tout ce qui m'intéresse exactement
tu as bien raison